EVERY NIGHT, REMEMBER AMERICA
NOW AND FOREVER AND "GUTFELD!"
IS NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHAT A SHOW, HAPPY
WEDNESDAY.
HERE HE IS GETTING FOOD FROM THE
SAME PLACE HE GETS HIS CLOTHES.
[LAUGHTER]
THE ONLY THING WORSE IS WHEN
HE'S NOT WEARING ANY.
AND I KNOW.
THE JUDGE HAS JOINED US.
JUST MADE IT HERE IN TIME, HERE
SHE IS ARRIVING AT THE STUDIO.
[TIRES SCREECHING]
WHEN WE SAY HERE COMES THE
JUDGE, IT'S A WARNING.
SADLY WE HAVE SOME
BREAKING NEWS, OUR 11:00 P.M.
COMPETITION OVER AT MSNBC IS
QUITTING.
STOP IT!
SAD TIME, JUDGE.
AFTER BEING REGULARLY SHELLACKED
BY THIS JUGGERNAUT OF A SHOW,
BRIAN WILLIAMS ANNOUNCED HE GOT
TIRED OF LOSING AND ANNOUNCED
HE'S LEAVING THE NETWORK.
THE MORE YOU CLAP, THE LESS I
TALK.
WHO KNEW HE WAS STILL EMPLOYED?
LET'S BE HONEST, HE'S NOT
LEAVING WITHOUT RACKING UP SOME
KEY ACHIEVEMENTS.
HE WAS KNOWN TO FABRICATE STUFF
BUT IN THE WRITING WORLD IT'S
KNOWN AS POETIC LICENSE.
IN THE NEWS WORLD IT'S KNOWN AS
BEING A DISHONEST SACK OF
[BLEEP].
HIM HE HAD QUITE THE RESUME
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HEAR IT FROM
HIM.
>> I HAD AN ILLUSTRIOUS CAREER,
VOTED "PEOPLE" MAGAZINE'S
SEXIEST MAN ALIVE FROM
1980 TO 1990, ALL WHILE LEADING
THE PITTSBURGH STEELERS TO FOUR
STRAIGHT SUPER BOWLS.
I COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT
MY WIFE ANGELINA JOLIE AND MY
OTHER WIFE, CLEOPATRA.
WHO I MARRIED IN A SECRET SEANCE
IN THE LOST CITY OF ATLANTIS.
I'LL FINISH MY MEMOIRS WHICH
WILL FOCUS ON MY DISCOVERY OF
THE POLIO VACCINE AND THE
CHARITY WORK READING ORPHANS
INSIDE A VOLCANO I MADE OUT OF
PILLOWS.
GOOD NIGHT, GOOD LUCK.
BY THE WAY, EDWARD R. MURROW
STOLE THAT FROM ME.
>> Greg: AS YOU KNOW THERE'S A
TRIAL GOING ON FOR KYLE
RITTENHOUSE AND IT SEEMS TO BE
COLLAPSING LIKE BRIAN STELTER
AFTER DOING TWO JUMPING JACKS.
A QUICK RECAP, IT BEGAN WITH THE
POLICE SHOOTING OF A PILOT KNIFE
WIELDING FELON IN KENOSHA,
WISCONSIN, FOLLOWING THREE DAYS
OF RIOTS AND PROPERTY
DESTRUCTION OR WHAT'S HE AND I
WOULD CALL PEACEFUL PROTEST, HE
TRAVELED TO KENOSHA ARMED WITH A
RIFLE PUBLICLY STATING HIS
MISSION WAS TO PROTECT
BUSINESSES AND VICTIMS.
IN THE ENSUING MELEE HE SHOT AND
KILLED TWO PEOPLE AND WOUNDED A
THIRD PART OF THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN ALLEGES HE'S A
MURDERER, HIS DEFENDERS AND
ANYBODY WITH AN IQ OVER 15
DESCRIBE IT AS A SELF-DEFENSE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE CLUELESS
PROSECUTION, THEY ARE PROVING IT
WAS SELF-DEFENSE TOO.
I HAVEN'T SEEN SOMEONE THIS
INEPT IN COURT SINCE
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
LEGAL EXPERT POINTS OUT A VIDEO
FROM THE SCENE, MURDER REMAINS
AN IMPOSSIBLE CHARGE TO PROVE.
I HAVEN'T WATCHED THE SHOW, BUT
LET'S SEE HOW THE MEDIA PORTRAYS
RITTENHOUSE.
>> KYLE RITTENHOUSE, THE
17-YEAR-OLD VIGILANTE.
>> KYLE RITTENHOUSE OF
VIGILANTE.
>> THE ARMED TEENAGE VIGILANTE.
HE'S BASICALLY WHAT YOU WOULD'VE
HAD AS ANY SCHOOL SHOOTER, HE
WAS GOING OUT TO SHOOT PEOPLE.
>> RUNNING AROUND SHOOTING AND
KILLING PROTESTERS.
>> A 17-YEAR-OLD VIGILANTE
ARGUABLY A DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
A WHITE FROM SUPPORTING --
>> HE WAS RADICALIZED BY TRUMP
IS, TOOK HIS AR-15 TO KENOSHA
AND BECAME A KILLER.
>> Greg: IT'S AMAZING HOW THEY
CAN SOUND EXACTLY THE SAME BUT
UNIQUELY STUPID IN THEIR OWN
WAY, ESPECIALLY THAT LAST GUY,
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
HIM.
IF I DIDN'T KNOW ANY BETTER I
WOULD THINK THEY WERE ALL ACTORS
WORKING FROM THE SAME SCRIPT,
ONE WHEN THEY STARTED WITH THE
ENDING AND CHANGED EVERY OTHER
WORD TO RACIST, MORE PREDICTABLE
THAN A THREES COMPANY MARATHON.
HERE'S SOMETHING FROM MY
FAVORITE CNN LEGAL ANALYST.
>> WHAT KIND OF IDIOT
17-YEAR-OLD GETS A GIANT GUN AND
GOES TO A RIOT, HE HAS NO
LICENSE, HE HAS NO TRAINING, HE
THINKS HE'S GOING TO SCRUB
GRAFFITI OFF WITH HIS AR-15?
STUPIDITY OF THIS.
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY GO WRONG?
A LOT WENT WRONG.
>> Greg: THAT'S A KICK.
YOU HAVE TO BE MORE RESPONSIBLE
BEFORE YOU WHIP SOMETHING OUT.
HE SHOULD KNOW IF YOU POINT
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE IS A
CHANCE IT WILL GO OFF.
MEANWHILE, "ABC NEWS" SUMMARY
FOCUSED ON THE LONE SURVIVOR OF
RITTENHOUSE'S ACTIONS LIKE HE
WAS SOME NAVY SEAL HUNTED BY THE
TALIBAN RATHER THAN PURSUING
RITTENHOUSE.
IT WAS A GREAT NARRATIVE UNTIL
YOU GET TO THE LAST FEW GRAPHS
OF ABCs COVERAGE AND YOU FIND
THIS.
>> IT WASN'T UNTIL YOU POINTED
YOUR GUN AT HIM, ADVANCED ON HIM
THAT HE FIRED.
>> CORRECT.
>> Greg: THE GUY WOUNDED BY
RITTENHOUSE ADMITS HE WAS
POINTING HIS GUN AT RITTENHOUSE
WHEN HE WAS SHOT.
THAT'S NO TINY DETAIL.
IF SOMEONE WALKS TOWARDS ME WITH
A GUN DRAWN IT'S EITHER A THREAT
OR I HAVE WANDERED INTO
DANA PERINO'S YARD.
LOOK AT THE PROSECUTORS WHEN THE
STORY DIDN'T GO AS PLANNED, THE
SAME REACTION MY DOCTOR HAS WHEN
I REMOVE MY PANTS.
THIS TRIAL BLEW UP IN THEIR
FACES LIKE ANTIFA PIPE BOMB.
FORGET THE LAUGHABLE
PROSECUTION, WHAT'S CONCERNING
IS HOW THE MEDIA PORTRAYS THE
ACTUAL FACTS.
THEY LIED ABOUT HAVING A GUN,
THEN ADMITS HE POINTED A LOADED
GUN AT RITTENHOUSE -- GAUGE,
WHICH IS A BAD NAME IN THE
FIREARMS CASE -- IT'S LIKE BEING
NAMED ALEC BALDWIN -- TURNED OUT
TO BE A TERRIBLE WITNESS FOR THE
PROSECUTION BUT THAT'S ON THE
MEDIA'S COVERING IT BACK OUT
THEM IT'S NOT SELF DEFENSE AT
ALL, IT'S GOT TO BE MURDER, OPEN
AND SHUT.
THEY ARE AS CROOKED AS IN AUNTIE
ANNE'S PRETZEL WITH SCOLIOSIS.
RITTENHOUSE IS FOUND NOT GUILTY,
HOW WILL THE ACTIVIST CLASS
REACT?
HOME DEPOT'S MIGHT HAVE A RUN ON
PLYWOOD FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF THE MEDIA
WANTS TO PRIME THE WRITERS TO
THINK RITTENHOUSE GOT AWAY WITH
MURDER AND WHY?
IT KEEPS THEM FROM EVER
ADMITTING THEY ARE WRONG, THEY
RUN FROM FACTS LIKE HUNTER BIDEN
RUNS FOR A BABY MAMA BUT IT
GUARANTEES MORE VIOLENCE WHICH
THEY SEE AS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
AND RATINGS TOO.
BRIAN WILLIAMS PICKED THE WRONG
TIME TO RETIRE.
IT WAS THE MEDIA'S EMBRACE OF
THE RIOTS WHILE CONDEMNING THE
POLICE THAT LED TO MORE
UNBRIDLED VIOLENCE.
WHEN THERE IS NO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WHO FEELS THAT
GAP?
I'LL GIVE YOU A HINT IT'S NOT
SOCIAL WORKERS OR MENTAL HEALTH
EXPERTS, IT'S PEOPLE LIKE KYLE
RITTENHOUSE.
IT WAS THE MEDIA'S EMBOLDENING
OF CRIMINALITY THEY DEEMED
NECESSARY TO PUNISH OUR EVIL,
RACIST SOCIETY AND COWARDLY
POLITICIANS RESPONDED WITH
POLICIES THAT SPONSORED THIS
UNSAFE WORLD.
WHY WOULDN'T SOME CITIZENS A
STEP UP TO PROTECT OTHERS?
WHO ELSE IF NOT YOU?
RITTENHOUSE AND OTHERS LIKE HIM.
WHEN YOU LEAVE PEOPLE WITH NO
OPTIONS, THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET.
MAY BE RITTENHOUSE ACTED IN
SELF-DEFENSE BUT HOW DID THE
MEDIA ACT?
THEY ARE NOT ON TRIAL BUT IF
THEY WERE IT WOULD TAKE A JURY T
OF GUILTY.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
SHE BOUGHT AN ENCYCLOPEDIA JUST
TO THROW AT PEOPLE.
HOST OF JUDGE JEANINE,
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO!
MORE BUBBLY THAN A BOTTLE OF
CHAMPAGNE SHAKING IN A PAINT
MIXER, FOX BUSINESS
CORRESPONDENT SUSAN LI!
HE'S GOT SOMETHING TO SAY AND
IT'S PROBABLY I DIDN'T BATHE
TODAY, MICHAEL LAWSON.
HER CAT IS TIRED OF CLEANING HER
LITTER BOX, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
KAT TIMPF!
I MEANT TO SAY YOU BROUGHT AN
ENCYCLOPEDIA BECAUSE YOU LIKE
THROWING THE BOOK AT PEOPLE BUT
IT CAME OUT OF MY MOUTH GARBLED
MUCH LIKE THE PROSECUTOR, WHAT
DID YOU MAKE OF THE PROSECUTOR
TODAY?
>> THE PROSECUTOR WAS SO DAMAGED
BY RITTENHOUSE TAKING THE STAND
AND THE PROSECUTOR WAS IN FACT
DAMAGED BEFORE EVEN TOOK THE
STAND BECAUSE THE MAIN
PROSECUTION WITNESS, UNDERSTAND
TWO PEOPLE ARE DEAD, ONE PERSON
WAS SHOT AT AND INJURED BY
RITTENHOUSE WHO SAID I HAD A
LOADED GUN AND I WAS ACTUALLY
GOING TOWARDS KYLE WHICH IS A
CLASSIC SCENARIO WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY SAY I'M ENTITLED TO USE
DEADLY PHYSICAL FORCE WENT
DEADLY PHYSICAL FORCE IS
CONFRONTING ME.
IT'S A CASE WITH THE D.A.
INDICTED THIS KID 48 HOURS AFTER
THE CRIME.
THAT MEANS THEY DID NO
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS IN THE AFTERMATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD, IT'S IN THE
AFTERMATH OF JACOB BLAKE
SHOOTING.
IT'S IN THE MIDDLE OF A RIOTS,
WHEN THE POLICE ARE STANDING
DOWN AND YOU HAVE THIS KID THE
POLICE EXPLORER, HE'S TRYING TO
DO SOME GOOD THINGS.
>> Greg: I TELL PEOPLE I AM A
CPR INSTRUCTOR BUT I'VE NEVER
TAKEN THE COURSE.
>> AND YOU PRACTICE IT ON THEM?
>> Greg: I DO IT WHEN I CAN,
I'M NOT PICKY.
SUSAN GOOD TO SEE YOU, HOW ARE
YOU DOING?
>> YOU NEVER PRACTICE CPR ON ME,
THAT GOD.
>> Greg: NOT THAT YOU'RE AWARE
OF.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING THIS?
THE PROSECUTION IS TRYING TO SAY
HE HAD NO RIGHT TO SELF-DEFENSE
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS BEATEN WITH A
SKATEBOARD, HE HAD A GUN POINTED
AT HIM AND THE PROSECUTOR
ACTUALLY SAID THEY NEVER SHOT
YOU.
YOU HAVE TO BE SHOT IN ORDER TO
FIGHT BACK.
>> ALL TRUE, HE SHOULDN'T BE
TRANSPORTING FIREARMS ACROSS
STATE LINES, HE SHOULDN'T OF
BEEN THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE
BUT I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
ALL THIS LAWLESSNESS AND CHAOS
MOTIVATES VIGILANTES LIKE KYLE
RITTENHOUSE, WHAT WAS HE
SUPPOSED TO DO?
>> Greg: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THIS, GOING ACROSS STATE LINES
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE TOOK AMTRAK
BUT IT'S WHERE HE WORKS, IT'S
WHERE HIS DAD LIVES, IT'S CLOSE.
>> HE WAS THERE EVERY DAY,
THAT'S WHERE HE WORKS.
>> Greg: I'M THINKING OKAY IF
I WERE 17 AND I REALIZED MY CITY
WAS GOING TO HELL AND I WAS A
GOOD KID TRYING TO DO GOOD
THINGS.
>> KNOW YOU WOULD NOT,
ABSOLUTELY NOT, YOU DON'T LIKE
GOING OUT IN PUBLIC, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GO AS A CHILD AND GET
AN AR-15.
THAT'S GOOD.
OBVIOUSLY THIS WAS SELF-DEFENSE
IT WAS RIDICULOUS TO SAY IT'S
ANYTHING BUT SELF-DEFENSE YOU
CAN ALSO SAY BEING A 17-YEAR-OLD
KID, SCHOOL IS OUT I KNOW WHAT
I'M DOING ON TUESDAY.
I'M GOING TO GO GET AN AR-15 AR5
[BLEEP].
I'M NOT A MOM BUT I WOULD NOT
WANT MY KID PLAYING WITH THAT
KID TO.
>> Greg: IF MY KID HAD AN
AR-15 -- I'LL BUY YOU SOME
CHICK-FIL-A, WILL NOT WATCH
BAYWATCH.
>> THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE'S A
MURDERER.
>> Greg: IF HE WAS TRULY
EARNEST AND BELIEVED HE WAS
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE, RIGHT?
>> I DON'T THINK HE HAS TO BE A
HERO IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE
SELF-DEFENSE.
I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
>> Greg: SO MANY VOICES IN
YOUR HEAD TELLING YOU --
>> THE CONSTITUTION IS THERE FOR
A REASON, YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
AN UPSTANDING PERSON IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO DEFEND YOURSELF
AGAINST SOMEBODY THAT IS
LITERALLY IN THE ACT OF TRYING
TO SHOOT YOU.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU STOPPED BY
GOODWILL ON THE WAY OVER HERE.
>> I'M GETTING THE DEALS.
I'M LIKE A SEAL IN A DUMPSTER UP
IN THIS BITCH.
>> Greg: YEAR ENCLOSE A
TRANSIENT COULD HAVE WORN.
>> AFTER THE TRANSIENTS ARE DONE
WITH THEM.
>> ALL THE CLOTHES YOU WEAR
BELONG TO PEOPLE NO LONGER
LIVING.
>> AND IT THROWS THE SEARCH DOGS
OFF, EVERYBODY WINS.
>> Greg: WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON
THIS?
>> I LOVE THIS KID COME OF THIS
IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THOSE
LAWLESSNESS.
CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS DUE, WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE POLICE STEPPING
UP AND EVERYBODY IS WATCHING
THINGS BURN, CITIZENS AREN'T
GOING TO STEP FORWARD?
>> Greg: AT THE LAST REFUGE,
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> SHAME ON THE FBI, THEY HAD
FOOTAGE THAT EXONERATED THIS KID
THEY MYSTERIOUSLY FOUND.
>> THAT IS THE POINT OF WHAT
THEY ARE DOING WHEN YOU
POLITICIZE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, WHEN YOU DON'T EVEN WANT
TO FIND OUT WHAT THE FACTS ARE,
WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS SO YOU CAN
INDICT THIS PERSON AND EVERYONE
ON THE LEFT IS SAYING HE'S A
MEMBER OF THE MILITIA, HE'S NOT
A VIGILANTE, WE GOT HIM ON VIDEO
HE'S ACTUALLY CLEANING CURSE
WORDS ON A WALL AND THEY SAW
VIDEO OF HIM.
HE HAD BODY ARMOR WHEN HE GOT TO
A POLICE FORCE AND HE GAVE IT TO
HIS FRIEND.
HE DIDN'T GO THERE TO KILL
ANYBODY.
>> THE FBI COULD COME FORWARD
WITH THAT VIDEO QUICKER!
TO BUSY TRACKING DOWN PARENTS AT
A PTA MEETING?
>> THEY SAID HE WAS A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST SOAP THEY'RE BOTH
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
>> THAT IS A TOUGH GIG RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE AN OPERATOR AT THE FBI.
WHAT YOU GOT, FENTANYL, PLEASE
HOLD.
WE HAVE A MISSING DIARY FROM A
VITAMIN GIRL, SEND EVERYONE.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S IN THAT
DIARY.
I BET THERE'S SOME DREAM
JOURNALING.
SOMETHING ABOUT A KID IN
CHEMISTRY CLASS, ADMITTED THAT
STUFF.
WHERE MY GOING?
I SHOULD PROBABLY GO TO A
COMMERCIAL.
>> I LIKE IT WHEN YOU NARRATE
YOUR OWN